all right baby
you know that um tech
tech is the new fossil fuel
think about that
bandwidth is the new oil
so just a light thought
just a light thought to get you um
just acclimated i guess to whatever
to or to nothing to nothing man
hope you're having a good day hope i'm
having a good day
i mean that's really that's the realest
i um i'm out here in the central east
i did a i did a skiing
this past weekend in
tahoe and they just shut it down again
there because of the disease
i mean i think you have more you have
excuse me you have a better chance of
dang
i'm getting bit by a damn sasquatch
then you do dying from this disease but
i don't make the rules you know i'm just
uh
i'm just one human and there's billions
so
um but yeah we had a nice time out there
went out there did a performance
actually for a company
this was called a corporate show
and those can be interesting you show up
and you don't know how it's going to be
usually you perform
somebody complains to the boss
and and somebody loses their job that's
usually what happens when they hire a
comedian
at a corporate show i mean i did one for
charmin a couple years ago and there was
almost a damn uh
fist fight at it and
how the hell people's fists fighting
when they're supposed to be making
toilet tissue
you know that's beyond me but that's
that's on god baby but um
what's that talking about oh so we did
it for this time the company called
battleborn batteries
battleborn batteries and they i thought
at first
you know ari mantis accompanied me there
and he said hey we're doing the show is
for battleborn
and i thought he meant uh breach births
you know c-sections baby
in c-sections let's be honest man
there's a section
uh there's b section and then once you
get to c-section bro it's really
damn they'll pull anything out of your
stomach at that point it's
a c-section baby's already
you know that's like the remedial
reading of children man if you're
already getting a c
and you haven't even you know barely
even alive
so a lot of times i feel like we should
probably do contact tracing on c-section
babies
you know they should tag them like they
do uh
you know sometimes you'll you'll see a a
rare egret or a damn uh
cormorant and it'll show up on your
property in a ha
have a tagging on and from far off it
looks like a bracelet looks like he went
to a nightclub the night before
you know looks like he might have spent
all night out at the stinkin
nest with his buddies or
you know over at the slippery branch or
whatever you know
but it turns out it's a tagging
government comes and they'll put a damn
wristband on a uh
on a falcon you know they'll put a damn
stopwatch on a
uh on a jayhawk
so they know what they're doing i mean
that's how when you think about how
crazy the government is that's crazy man
that's pretty crazy but what's that
yeah so battle born batteries that's the
company and it's just a company
and they do batteries and they do uh
i guess special hardcore batteries
that'll survive anything a snowstorm
flooding funeral you know uh
second coming i mean jesus could pass
through town and that damn battery will
still be working but
uh so anyway we had a good time with
that company and it went well sometimes
you know when you invite a comedian to
an hr issue it can be a real
you know to a company it can be a real
issue
so but we had a nice time and beautiful
people over there
this fella sean and uh and just a great
group of guys man
and and women too guys and women baby
both gender son so
what else man oh god
oh somebody brush my teeth
i can't even handle that sometimes oh
i'll tell you this we saw a lady
we were at the casino in the gift shop
at night and a lady in there that's an
adult
this an adult lady so this ain't no
novice you know
this isn't a first time into a snack
plate i mean this lady she sounded like
an alien though
she was talking on it was like kind of
like a diverse lady talking on the
phone on face uh not facetime facetime
audio or whatever
you know uh
and the person on the other end is like
what do they have
and she's in this gift shop and she
named
everything that they have
she's like they got uh they got rolos
they got um lays uh
ruffles um they got
uh pringles uh they got green pringles
orange pringles uh purple pringles
um they got these like kind of little
like
like kind of brown mazes with salt on
them like these little like
figure eights oh pretzels um
they got neckties they got clip-on they
got dove
ice cream they got drumstick uh
they got butterfinger they got certs
they got
raspberry certs they got uh
they got five hour energy they got six
hour energy
they got uh this and the person like
what did they have and then she
bro she was starting a whole new thing
they got t-shirts they got um
they got welcome to reno t-shirts they
got
uh they got a neck brace they got we uh
they got um playing cards they got
hershey kiss
um what do they have they have um
they got uh what else they got cinnamon
whiskey they got
gin uh they got sunglasses
they got um they got whatchamacallits
oh they got uh kahlua
and then she every now and then she was
like let me go ask them if they have
that let me go ask them if they have
that
and she would go over to the counter
oh bro it just didn't make any sense and
i mean it literally made no sense they
got gummy bed they got smoked salmons
they got um coffee
oh but man
that's humanity and where would we be
with that i mean we were dying laughing
i it just
it was so hard to be in the store and
watch this lady just do this
just literally unfair oh they got um
they got milk they got chocolate milk
they got diet milk
um they got uh
twizzlers they got uh red vines
dear god speaking of god
thank you guys uh for being here and
being a part of my life today
and helping me get through this uh just
life help me get through life
you know life uh it was a surprise to
all of us
it really was uh today's musical
intro is by larry fleet
where i find god it's a it's a country
song
i think but it's a there's something
really human about it man
and uh it'll hit you right in the stair
steps
gang brother
come on there
[Music]
they got rolos but not a hit rock bottom
he paid my tab and put me in a cab
but he didn't have to as he could see
i was hurting come on baby
oh i wish i'd got his name
cause i didn't feel worth saving
but he saved me just the same
[Music]
day out on the water
when the fish just wouldn't buy come on
hold with me baby
[Music]
come on
the chevrolet
[Music]
that's where i find god
come on man
[Music]
sometimes later
whether
that's where i find god
[Applause]
y'all got to go get on that right there
that's larry fleet
where i find god
and it is powerful man when you think
about that where you find god
you know i remember place times in my
life where i found him uh
you know there's a when i go to my
mother's house sometimes i like to lay
on her bed and sometimes uh the sun will
just kind of hit her bed coming in from
the window and
and that there's just something about
that space
and that that moment that
that little that time
where i feel like there's like
you know i feel god then um
when i see when you see a little baby
when you see a little baby do something
you know
and not something staged like they had
those two little kids hugging on the
internet
i mean something real you know when you
see a little baby hug
his parent or you know uh
learn something new when you see in his
eyes he's learning something new you
know
i think there's moments like that where
you you just feel
like that's god just making another
stitch in the quilt you know
that's where he puts his uh
thread through and brings it back out
things like that there's little things
that keep you holding on you know
when you see your grandmother laugh
you know when you when one of your
friends has a child you know a close
friend
um
i think it's just you know god is that
he's that soapy water man he's gonna
find his way through the cracks and
uh and i love that song man larry fleet
where i find god
and some people don't have a god and
that's okay man um
i i think it's a tough way to go through
life i've struggled in my life with my
relationship with a higher power
and uh and some days it's stronger than
others and
some days it's not there at all uh but
um but man that song
that song helps me i don't know
it's something you know music has that
power
music has that power man help you do
some things that you can't do by
yourself
and some of those things are things your
feelings want to do
and places they want to go and a song
really is just a
you know it's just a bunch of sounds
that are a key
and if they're right man sometime it'll
unlock you
and it'll unlock you to love it'll
unlock you to dance it'll unlock you to
some of this [ __ ] will unlock you to
damn start a fire you know
or to lift weights i mean it's just the
the music
you know every song every beat kind of
it's a different tickle
and some of them tickle you on the side
and some of them tickle you in the damn
ass
and some of them just damn tickly on the
neck and it's just you know it's a
they're all it's all a different game
but
anyway good to be here with you today
man that's larry fleet where i find god
you can check that out um
so damn uh do they have gobstoppers
uh they have um
unbelievable what's going on i i'm still
looking for a vehicle
so i've been trying to do carmax
and carmax is like it's kind of like a
lost and found for vehicles but you got
to pay for them
and i'm waiting
i really want a ford ranger like a 2019
maybe
so i'm hopeful for that um
[Music]
i went and looked at some houses the
past two days
that was good went to the doctor um
dude i went so
i went to the doctor right and
i go into the doctor's office and um
[Music]
i went to the first black doctor i've
ever been to
and it was just interesting and i never
it never in my head ever
crossed my mind that you know i've seen
black doctors on television uh
i've thought about black doctors you
know african-american doctors black
doctors
and but i've never been to one
so i go in and there was there's just
like there was
it was just it just came to my attention
you know and it doesn't make me racist
that doesn't make me wrong or anything
it just
at first i was like dang i wonder
because then i thought that black people
probably have been going to a lot of
maybe i've been going to a lot of white
doctors their whole life i don't know
i mean when i was growing up they didn't
have black doctors
except for cliff huxtable you know bill
cosby
and he was uh you know he was doing
rapes
so but that don't mean nothing i mean he
was on the show he wasn't
on the show he was just doctoring
this when he was just still you know
doing uh
you know birth yeah i think he was a
baby doctor
so he was that you know this is that's
way after rape you know that's
that's babies so anyway i just had never
been to a black dog i just had never
i'd never been there because they didn't
have it when i was growing up
and then in l.a a lot of i guess yeah i
don't know i've been in some middle east
and i've
just never been to a black doctor so
anyway and then i thought man it must be
wild because a lot of black kids when i
was young probably had to grow up going
to
white doctors
and if you have like a lot of racial
questions in your head you go in there
dude i bet you're wondering like is this
white doctor gonna save me you know
um it was definitely interesting i
started talking to a friend of mine
about it
and they said well to a black friend of
mine and they said well you know a lot
of black people liked why they like to
go to black churches because people
sometimes will
you know people there's just a
you know there's a tribal kind of
instinct sometimes especially i think if
you're thinking about going to heaven
um or at least there used to be i don't
know if it's that much anymore because
i'll see
like uh joel osteen
videos and it's i mean it's so diverse
at his crowds and
um so this is probably just an older
you know just some older stuff but it
was just really interesting i just got
in there and i was like is this guy
is he is he gonna know
because i think part of my wonder was
does it feel different to be
black like just does it physically feel
different like if i explain to him a
white pain
or just a pain that i have in my white
body
is it gonna see does it register the
same to him
you know like
i don't know it was just interesting um
and he was great man super super nice
young guy
um you know but it was definitely
it was just interesting because i'd
never been i'm like if i
you know if i say there's something
hurts in my back does it
like does he have the same feeling it
was just it was interesting
and i think yeah in churches i think
people think sometimes oh man it's
will it can i get to heaven or will i
get you know is this
worship lee like do they have the same
like if i if i'm white do i gotta get
you know do i do do
i need a white person to help me get to
heaven if i'm black do i need a black
person to help me get to heaven
um
so it was it was just an injury it was
just an interesting thing that happened
man i didn't
i just walked in i was like why never
so i was like yeah i think i'm at you
know my my antidepressants aren't
working
and but he was totally
he was awesome man so
uh not that he wouldn't be but it was
just a new experience bro
so it made me think like dang when i was
young all of my friends that were black
had to go to white doctrine because i
don't know if they had black doctors
back then
and if you lived in a household where
you had family members saying like white
people or there were white people the
devil or something
then how would it imagine how awkward it
would be to go get a diagnosis then from
a white doctor
it must have been i don't it must have
just been wild
i don't know man
but that's some stuff you know that's
just kind of what's been going on i've
been doing some yoga at home
uh did a show here the other night in
nashville
so thank you everybody that came through
i've been doing some yoga man
here's how i do yoga people want to say
well theo how do you do yoga
this is what i do so i'm renting an
airbnb
right now and that's where you just get
a place for a little while and
it's kind of sketchy i mean you could do
you could run a whorehouse how do you do
whatever you want
but i'm just doing life just sleeping
eating
uh that sort of deal so i put on yoga
with adrien
and it's this white girl based out of um
austin uh
yeah based at austin and so um they got
barbecue chips
um so anyway i put it on i'll put my mat
out i got one of the long mats
there's different lengths of yoga mats
you can get i get the long one
there's nothing i hate more than the
yoga mat that's a little short whenever
you're like doing it and your kind of
foot's hanging off the back
and it's kind of like when you have a
shirt on that's a little too short
it's like oh so i get the long one
i'll light a couple candles i'll cut out
the how cut out the house lights
i light a few candles brought a little
couple seance pieces you know
and a lot of my candles have been used
in seancery so
um so you know i'm not surprised i'm in
a downward dog in a damn
you know a you know a ghost travels
right up under my ass bro that's where
i'm at
so anyway i'll put on yoga with adrian
there's like about 10 different ones i
like to do
i'll light a couple candles unscented
i don't need you know i don't need to be
smelling peppermints while i'm laying
there do they have peppermint they got
peppermints they got um
mint juleps they got um wrigley's
uh so that's it i'll lay out the mat
i put on a couple candles i'll put it on
my computer i'll turn my email off so
the thing doesn't ding
and i'll do a good session man and i
start to like it more and more and it
makes me feel pretty good
uh but i do yoga with adrien
and and i noticed the reason i like her
is for one
she goes really step by step into
her voice
there's something about the cadence and
the
volume of her voice that's just
it helps me just travel through yoga
you know just like i was saying earlier
about different songs different sounds
um have a different gravitas to them
and they stick to you different
and someone will fill your ears up and
someone will just get make you gassy in
your head
like you got damn at you know like you
got ass in your head bro
and i think that's why you know people
like different music because certain
some people like a tambourine
i don't mind a tambourine maybe for a
little while and like a janice joplin
song
or maybe subtly if leon bridges is
hitting something kind of hardy
but i don't do somebody just loosen just
loose goosing around with a tambourine
bruh
do they have weapons they got guns
dude i can't i'll i can't handle that
somebody about to get slaughtered out so
um but yeah that's what's new with me
man
i'm just
you know uh just going to diverse
doctors
because you also think like man if this
if this doctor has like some kind of
like would they have some kind of
vendetta where they're going to
prescribe me a
you know a damn net you know uh you know
a tart transplant
but then i think man black people must
have thought that forever if they always
had to go to white doctors
or you know i don't know i just i don't
know if they had a lot of black
and i'm also referencing when i was
growing up i just don't know if they had
a black doctor when i was growing up and
i didn't know at the time i was a child
i don't know where black you know i just
thought
black kids always looked pretty healthy
to me they were the you know most
athletic they just seemed like they was
always doing pretty good
so but i don't know man just
i never thought about it where were
black kids going to the doctor when i
was a kid
um
[Music]
i mean it was a small town we probably
all went to the same damn doctor dude
um let's get into some calls some calls
came in we got some
some unique things um we had uh that
call that came in about the ps5 which is
really nice uh last week and
uh somebody wanting to share that uh
let's see what we can uh
get into right here here we go and thank
you guys for being a part of this past
weekend
if you have any thoughts on anything
that's ever discussed on here mentioned
you can call the hotline
985-664-9503
we're open to any constructive
criticisms always here merry christmas
to everybody
gang hey theo name's caden
uh man i just got to get your thoughts
on on the vaping stuff
man a couple of my buddies have been
hitting that sparky nasty here for a
while and they've been
they done switched over to the jewel or
the vape
whatever and uh man i don't know what to
think about it man they just keep trying
to get me to
hit on that thing and i don't know about
hitting on the toker
man i got to get your thoughts on it
holla back at me thanks brother
all right thank you so much there caden
and uh
yeah cause jeweling is different people
do
jeweling you'll see somebody they gotta
you know hey you jewel
just gargling vowels just
[Music]
you jewel when i was young jewel was a
child person's name
so somebody said you jewel i would be
like no i'm theo
who is she um
and now yeah the kids got everything you
know they got tiramisu flavored
watermelon bro
dog when i was doing you had to hit that
cigarette baby
like a damn man you had to stand there
like
just a [ __ ] loose piece of forest
fire just
you know what i'm saying you had this a
smoker had to smoke
there wasn't no secret eh you know this
thing
also doubles as a hard drive you can
keep up like just like 60
jpegs on here
bro you you jew
and y'all got all kind of flavor they
got lasagna
they got everything man they got regular
mint they got
cement they got menthol peanut butter
bruh everything man they got lactate
somebody just hitting a damn lactate
jewel say their bowels can't handle
regular jewel
[ __ ] what when i was young you had to
smoke
and you had to risk getting busted
that's another thing about a jewel
i see people jeweling on a plane
i see people just juice blowing into
their pocket
blowing in into the dog's mouth they got
a little rescue dog on there with him
little schnauzer no you know
they chimney and that [ __ ] up
when i was you know you had to smoke you
had to go hard
and you had to blow yet i blow it and
there was no hide in that smoke
that [ __ ] was the industrial revolution
baby
i mean you look like a damn sawmill out
there just hitting winston's
and you smelled like it now somebody
comes in the house they're out there
they've been hitting that cherry or that
paprika
you know somebody comes in the house and
they've been hitting uh the
uh ricotta they just did
40 grams of ricotta cheese jewel outside
it's just different man this [ __ ] is
weak now
so i say put it down baby put it down
and pick up a real cigarette
pick up that real killer bruh
you know what i'm saying have some honor
get japanese with it pick up a
real cigarette and hit that bastard
cause you out here hitting these fake
dude it can store up to
like 30 jpegs in it
yeah man and it's peach cobbler flavored
[ __ ] i don't care
get that old dog i remember hitting a
marlboro red bra made one of my eyes
closed for a month
i remember that [ __ ] was for real
and you had to come back to the table
smell you had to hide the smell
you over there rubbing gum all over you
in the garage trying to you spraying
double d
double d 40 on your buddy trying to get
the smoke off of him
everybody you when you come back to the
thanksgiving table smell like a damn oil
change
but you had to go through something now
you got people sucking out out here
sucking on a damn usb
port
dude my buddy's in the uh jewel uh he's
a professional
yeah he's in the semis in reno this
weekend
put it down y'all ain't doing [ __ ] bro
pick up a regular cigarette dude
smoke them for 20 30 years watch your
skin give in a little
and then go see the lord have some
respect for yourselves
uh so that's what i think of jewel man
it's hard to go off on that but i had to
let you know man
um what else dude here we got a call
that came in
uh and i'm also gonna let you know right
now that if you need help
looking i need it man i've been seeing a
therapist
uh on line and in person
and it's going good and i'm not giving
up my brother made me commit that i
would go see a therapist for one year
um so i'm glad he's holding me
accountable to that a little bit and
uh and i need it you know i need it
um so what i'm telling you right now is
that better help is there for you better
help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating fast
the services available worldwide
you know i remember in my town i grew up
in i might have been a little bit you
know
nervous or if i go see the therapist
well hell i play basketball with her
husband so
is she gonna tell him what's he gonna
think you know
and well he and i both went to school
together and is that gonna be weird and
she and i went to school together hell i
she rejected me four times is it gonna
be weird now that i'm in there just
telling her what's wrong with me
yeah well it could be i don't know but
if it is
then there's better help better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid
is available better help want you to
start living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over 500 000 people taking
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional and i know that actually
it's more than a million people now
special offer for this past weekend
listeners get
10 percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
theo 10 off your first month
theo no one is going to know except you
and your therapist
if you want to just zoom if you want to
just text if you want to just
email if you want to facetime all those
are options
through betterhelp i've used it and you
can too
today's episode is also brought to you
by raycon's newest model
the perfect christmas gift the everyday
e25 earbuds they're the best ones yet
six hours of playing time seamless
bluetooth pairing
more bass
a more compact design a noise isolating
fit raycon earbuds are stylish and
discrete
no dangling wires or stems
the company was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities
like jr smith mike tyson rich the kid
melissa etheridge
give them a try raycon has a 45-day free
return policy
so there you go right there you get this
christmas gift for somebody
somebody who needs it somebody who wants
more bass somebody wants their uh
their earbuds to last longer raycon is a
free 45-day return policy so you can
make sure they're the pair of wireless
earbuds
for you the newest model the e25 it's
the best ones yet they're premium
wireless earbuds you can get them at
half the price
of the other guys for a limited time get
off your order at buy raycon dot com
slash theo
that's b u y r a y c o
n dot com slash t h e
o for a special fifteen percent discount
on raycon wireless earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal's running by raycon.com
theo so let's go to another call here
the hotline 985-664-9503
hey buddy hey theo this is ryan um
i want to get your thoughts on what it
means that uh
you know the ufos are definitely real
now and like whether that
kind of i don't know affects us as as
human beings
makes you think about you know time
travel and stuff like that
um just in general doesn't impact your
your daily thinking that you can
you know look up at the sky and say
what's out there
all right buddy thanks a lot again
you for the call ryan you know recently
they had a thing
an article and it said uh
israeli space security chief
says extraterrestrials exist and trump
knows
about it he said a galactic federation
has been waiting for humans to reach a
stage where we will understand
what space and spaceships are haim
eshed has said this
um
said the aliens were equally curious
about humanity
and were seeking to understand the
fabric of the universe
and he said that they have been waiting
until today for humanity to develop
and reach a stage where we will all
understand in general what space
and spaceships are
they also added that president donald
trump was aware of the
extraterrestrial's existence
and had been on the verge of revealing
information
but was asked not to in order to prevent
mass hysteria according also to the
report
uh haims uh the former head of israeli's
defense ministry space
directorate told an israeli newspaper
that earthlings have been in contact
with a galactic federation and that
there's an underground base in the
depths of
mars where there are american astronauts
and
alien representatives
look you know to answer your question
right you said that we know now that
they're real
we i don't know i don't know if i
believe any news that comes out anymore
it's all subject to what you believe
so i think the news used to be you know
there was a level of
what we thought was reality of it to it
and i don't know if that's the case
anymore i really don't
um so do i know if this article's legit
i have no idea
you think that there's like a board me
it makes it sound like there's a meeting
every year and the aliens decide
if we're ready to see the aliens
i don't know that sound like they're
like well how's this year been and
you're like well
um you know uh well we
you know we're arriving at the ps5 right
now
and there is we have picture frames that
can
change the picture you know and they're
solar powered
so we're you know we're still struggling
to recycle
but uh that's where we're at and then
it's like
rejected and then the next year they're
like are you
how all right guys how's things this
year you ready to accept aliens
and they're like well we're having like
a lot of widespread
racial disputes and um but we do
you know there is a new popular like
bidet attachment that people are buying
for their toilets they don't have to
wipe their butt
it's like uh rejected
dude it reminds me of that scene in um
shawshank redemption where he keeps
going every year to try to get
denied denied denied denied and then
finally
brooks was here baby i'm gonna kill
myself by the grocery
praise god baby um
so yeah that just seems weird that
there's a meeting every year
and that there's like discussion i just
can't
until people are ready we will
never be ready
people are beating the [ __ ] out of each
other for ps5s
at and the malls aren't even open
think about that there are
shooting i'm sure there's a shooting
right now if you put your ear
up to a bowl of dirty water you can hear
us
shooting in flint michigan right now
probably for a pair of children's arola
skates
we are not ready for aliens
now some positives i think is it would
give us all somebody to battle against
because i'll tell you straight up bro
some alien shows up over there in
memphis or something
some brother's gonna pop him off bro
real talk
or if he shows up out there in oregon a
couple of white dudes gonna sneak over
and abduct his ass you know
make a chili out of them
so i i don't know i mean
i mean the whole the alien thing always
to me do i think that we're the only
people
here like the only beings i don't know
and people say well it's selfish to
think that well
i don't think it i don't know
i think we're in the very kinder years
of
learning about all of that kind of stuff
the simple fact that we're still
operating on fuels like uh
you know gasoline and um
whatever else they're using octane
i think in the future people will be
able to [ __ ] travel on a good idea
you know
you'll have a couple good ideas and
that'll fill up your idea cube and then
you'll
be able to use the lightning created
from that to
migrate to different areas i think you
know we're just on this we're on this
very
novice plane right now
so yeah i think uh it's gonna be
interesting down in the down the line
now i do think this about aliens i think
it's wild that
aliens always trying to get in
everybody's booty and body
everybody that gets abducted by aliens
they trying to [ __ ] them bro
i mean who are they you know what i'm
saying
or aliens just a bunch of like just
dudes like bunch of drunk dudes in vegas
or something
because every time they pick somebody up
the first thing they tell people is they
try to
tu you know you know touch inside their
booties
and that makes me sad bro but
but that's aliens man so do we even want
to know these people what if you
what if every time you introduce your
you know somebody to your friend uh
amos and amos try to sneak up in their
ass while they doing something
you know they at the house they looking
for a little you know their car keys and
amos tries to slip in them cheeks bro
you'd say hey amos dude you gotta go
home
so that's the thing that's aliens
that's aliens boy and yeah
i don't if aliens showed up here on
earth we're still i mean
we're basically probably the denny's of
the galaxy
when you think of that nobody's stopping
here we got a couple of [ __ ]
uh a couple of gas powered
jets that can go you know that travel
around like dude they're not they're
like what are y'all doing over here with
these paper airplanes
y'all need to freaking throw a
battle-borne battery into one of these
things
and really see the see the future
um what else that's all i had man on
that
so are they real
i hope we find out here's the shitty
thing what if you don't get to find out
in your lifetime
oh i mean you won't know but still
you'll know towards the end
i bet that's a lot of people last
thought man [ __ ]
do they have fritos um they got um
they got hostess cakes they got ice
cream they got white ice cream they got
brown ice cream so
uh what else we got here let's take
another call
right here and then we're gonna get uh
into that ps5 let's get into the ps5 man
here we go right here this was the call
that came in last week
we had a fellow named kenny from
portland who wanted to help out a single
mom
and uh i had an idea here i have a
playstation 5 that i got from my work
uh i'm not really a big gamer but i
would like to offer that to one of your
struggling single moms
so if you have any ladies out there that
are
trying to make your kid happy on the
holiday i have a playstation 5 that i'll
be willing to
donate only because your show gives me
hours of entertainment throughout the
week uh you're very positive
i love the things that you have to say
and gang game
gang brother thank you man you know i
needed to hear that again today
you know i need constant reminders to
put myself in a good place
um and we did we had some calls that
came in man and
uh here was uh here was the first one
that came in
and so i feel like that that's kind of
the fairest way to go about it
mike from philadelphia pennsylvania just
wanted to say
gang gang love everything you're doing
appreciate everything you're doing as
well
um i was just calling i watched your
thanks living episode
and i heard a gentleman call in saying
he was offering up
one of those playstation 5 hitters to a
uh
single mother and i just wanted to maybe
nominate my
my sister she works really hard she has
two kids
uh one's eight one's ten they're real
big in the video
game so i thought that would be perfect
for him um
if you haven't already chosen someone
i'd really like you to consider her her
name's dana
she lives in maryland with my two
nephews and they're they're great kids
she's an awesome mom so really
appreciate everything you're doing
thank you thank you mike i didn't mean
to cut you off there man but um
yeah we're gonna we'll connect you with
kenny and um
and you know that's candyman that's
kenny helping out there thinking that he
won something at
a work or however he wanted and then he
can give it away man that's really
beautiful
um we just we had some nice calls that
came in
and i didn't think like man yeah it's
kind of a bummer that is grateful
is grateful that that uh we're able to
connect the dots there and and help the
kiddos get a ps5
um those things are hot commodity bro
damn
dude somebody would be dying of cancer
you offering some plasma they say no but
you hit them with that
and they want it bruh so but i thought
hey we could hit a couple of people back
and see what else we could do let me um
let's see if we can call that guy though
dang he's not home i was gonna call him
in in
person and just you know just tell him
hello and uh
so then what i'm gonna say is this man
let's think about this so um
what i'm talking about is uh let's hit
some other people up
we got this call that came in let's hear
it
hey theo it's west from minneapolis man
i uh
just listened to this past weekend i
heard the guy call in about the ps5 for
a single mom and uh
i got an excellent single mom that uh
she's uh working to get her kid back she
has them about half the year right now
and she's gonna have him over christmas
um she she took me in about two months
ago a really good friend and
helped me out of a really hard situation
helped me get on my feet
staying there right now she ain't making
me pay nothing and
man she has a really great kid who was
here over thanksgiving and he'll be back
for christmas and
he's a big gamer and you know she
manages a gas station so she's out there
grinding
every day but you know it'd be great to
give him a
great christmas that he could remember
amen brother i think we can help out
with that um
let me give you a buzz right now see
what we can do
nobody want to answer the phone anymore
but i think it's the uh
government
hello what's up wes bro how you living
man
good who's this this is theo man theovon
the comedian
oh get out of town man what's going on
with you cat daddy what's up
brother not much brother's looking for
the lord you know me boy
amen amen damn dude my buddy said the
other day i said dude i'm looking for
the lord my buddy said dude the lord
ain't lost
everywhere he's everywhere man how's
your day going
good man i'm gonna say work man my boss
had me run down to fedex to drop off
this package i sell cars man and uh
i'm selling a car out of state i had to
fedex some papers overnight so
i'm on the road right now nice baby uh
well thanks for picking up man
yeah i appreciate your call man it's
really nice of you to call just that you
left on the uh hotline
uh yeah we'd already found somebody had
already had called before they got the
ps5 but
we have uh there's a company that helps
us out sometimes this company called
magic mind and they wanted to offer uh
a ps4 or i think it's a ps4 and a
television maybe i don't know if the
kiddo would you know if that would be
something that they would like
man that would be amazing dude you have
no idea how awesome you just made my day
awesome bro well dude it's nice you to
think about somebody else man
you know man she helped me out i was in
a really bad spot i moved to texas for a
year
uh didn't really work out i had a issue
with a roommate that
ended up turning violent man i had to
leave it was just
crazy and she said you know i've never
really been in a position to help
somebody and i'm in that position now
and
you're a good friend come on up and
she's just been helping me get back on
my feet man got a job and
she's she's great man she's great you
couldn't be going to a nicer person
amen bro well that's awesome dude that
makes me feel good bro
for sure yeah thanks man yeah just
thanks for thinking of somebody else and
um
yeah i'll uh i'll just follow up with
you i'll hit you up after
or the producer sean or nick will hitch
up after and just get it all
set up but yeah i think i can't remember
exactly what he donated but i think he
donated a ps4 in a television so
that's so amazing man i i saw this call
coming from louisiana and i was like
here comes another [ __ ] saying
that my car or my
my car's warranty needs to get uh
extended or something yeah bruh look
that's gonna be the next call baby
that's the next car
yeah actually i want to talk to you
right now about your warranty extension
wes if you have a minute
oh damn they got me
[Laughter]
well bro look man keep living the way
you're living man i'm proud of you brian
i'm just
you know i'm just grateful that you
called in man it's cool dude
amen man i appreciate you man i listen
to you all the time so i really
appreciate the call it's so great to
hear from you
dude you made me feel good man i
appreciate it man have a good day dude
and we'll circle up with you bro and
thanks for thinking of somebody else man
awesome peace okay
damn that hit me in the feelings a
little bit man
what else can we do here let me see what
else we can
do here
man it's nice i'm going to think about
that lady you know it's hard in our
lives to reach out and say i can help
you
especially these days there's so many
barriers that ca that that get put
up you know
you know a lot you know i get long as
i'm safe in my home and i'm in my place
and i
you know it'll be uncomfortable and just
we've gotten so kind of separate
sometimes that
helping other people used to be kind of
i think kind of in more of an
innate thing and now it's because we've
gotten so
solitary it almost feels weird sometimes
i think
isn't that strange that it feels weird
to help somebody to invade in their life
and as a society even we're getting more
to like oh if you need help go to the
government go to the
city go to the
you know it's no longer like um oh what
can i can i help
and i think a lot of people do still
think that way but i think just as a
society we
um or not can i help but what how can i
help or
i don't know i'm not judging anybody i'm
not saying that i'm just thinking out
loud i'm just um
i think i kind of had i felt like i
hadn't really done anything nice for
somebody in a while and then just
thinking about that and and i didn't do
anything
you know that's magic mind who hit me up
today and said that they wanted to
donate and
but uh let me see man
here we got one let's take it
hi theo my name is tim carter um i
sincerely just honest to god i really
hope you hear this
um so i
i live in portland oregon and i uh
heard kenny call in with his donation of
uh playstation 5 and i would
like to nominate um a lady that i know
uh her name is larissa and she has a
seven-year-old daughter
named annabelle and um
last year right before kogan
they moved to portland from mcminnville
uh
to take a new job um
the new job opportunity almost
immediately didn't work out once she got
here
kovan set in and she actually had to
become like a full-time uber
and lyft driver well i figured let's
call in right now and see what we can do
loud why is this loud
hello hey what's up man this is theo
vaughn bro
uh i'm calling just about you called a
couple um
[Music]
a couple days ago about the uh about the
podcast about the we're talking about
the playstation
yes sir my gosh i wow how are you
thank you so much for calling oh i'm
doing good man tim is this tim
this is tim yes thank you oh yeah man no
worries man thank you for calling bro uh
yeah i just appreciate it man i thought
your message was really nice and um
you know i just thought you know thanks
for even checking out the podcast and
for
you know just thinking about somebody
else uh especially this time of year
we can i just um before i forget because
i
i just think that you're probably pound
for pound the
i i don't want to i hopefully you won't
take this the wrong way but i think that
you're so underrated dude i i just think
you just how you are and the things that
you do and the things that you say there
could never be
another character or comedian or just
entertainer like you you are so unique
and i appreciate you so much so i just
wanted to get that out of the way first
of all
thanks bro well it's nice you to say man
yeah you know it's funny when you say
that just now i think there's something
about if somebody says
that you're unique like i think in my
life i just want to be unique i think we
all want to
you know uh but i think i've always had
some weird obsession with it i think um
but that's really kind to you to say
that man that's very thoughtful uh
my pleasure yeah dude so we gave away
the playstation somebody else had called
before you but we wanted to we want to
do something nice
so i'm trying to think what do you think
we could do i mean we we
you know we could give uh what what do
you think she could use
you know um
i think of her i i kind of think of
just the difficulties that she's gone
through in this transition
and probably the what i would think
about more is probably just her little
daughter
her little daughter wants to be um
a youtube sensation so bad she likes to
play this game called roblox and she
likes to make her own little videos and
she's very enthusiastic and everything
and of course her being a single mom you
know she's been
home uh during covert for like the last
however long
seven eight months and she just moved up
here
and had just give you a super super
short backstory so she was
when i met her she was going through
some sexual harassment turmoil in her
work
and so um i i kind of gave her a little
bit of money a little bit of
momentum to to come to portland and then
when she moved she
dropped everything to come up here and
take a job
and then covet hit and they weren't able
to offer her the position
so um so yeah
and then it just hasn't i know that's
such a hard question i
i don't know what yeah and it might have
been a little too uh
you know it might be too open-ended or
something i don't know what they call a
question that like you
you know it's just too vague but um so
let me think man so i'm thinking
you know why don't we we'll set what
maybe we could just at least set you
guys up with like a gift card or
something maybe
to best buy or to some other place where
if she wants to get like a
you know a youtube cam or something like
you know i don't know maybe
i don't know what some of the cameras
are called but nick will know man so
why don't we um why don't we set you
guys up with a 500
gift card to uh to a place that could be
helpful and
i'll have nick or sean call and uh and
you can
just give us her information and um
and we'll go from there wow tio i just
i just don't know what to say man i just
i wasn't expecting this
at all and i think that's a great idea
and i think yeah that's just open-ended
and she can do with it
you know and that will be just such a
great christmas this is her first
christmas in portland and that'll oh
that will just be so awesome so awesome
thank you
man thank you bro you know i don't know
i don't know these people but it's just
you know it's your own kindness and your
own thinking about somebody else and
um you know it's funny that guy calls
and he offers a playstation and i wasn't
even thinking today like oh let's think
of ways we can do things or give out
anything and uh and it just kind of it's
funny how one thing like that kind of
spurns the other ones you know
well and i was worried too like when i
listened to the episode and first of all
i think that was also the robert finley
episode and my dad
loved that song but um quick side note
there yeah that's a good song dude
you gotta take it
but i think um i was worried that maybe
you know everybody was going to call in
and
maybe somebody like you would call in
you think oh this guy just wants the
playstation for himself or whatever so
i'm glad that the the phone call came
across as sincere
yeah no he did i thought it for a second
but then i quit thinking it man but
that's just
that's just something inside of me that
always wants to think the devil first
you know
well cool man well look i think it's a
thoughtful gesture and uh i'm glad that
we could be a part of it man and um
yeah i'll have the guys follow up and
merry christmas brun you just pass it on
to her and just let her know that uh
just that people are thinking about her
even if sometimes she feels like maybe
people aren't or
maybe she doesn't feel that way at all
but just let her know people are always
thinking of her
my god theo and you have a great
christmas man god bless you and yeah
keep
keep pushing man because you're gonna
you're gonna get to that bill burr
level you're just uh once people see you
man once enough people see you
it's the sky's the limit for your talent
i just know it
well thanks bro i appreciate it man it's
been uh
even in a rough year it's been an okay
year man and i'm grateful to have the
podcast and just to have you know to
know that there's other people out there
that are
um you know that just as a group we
don't give up you know we keep uh just
trying our best so
all right gang tim bruh be good man
okay thank you all right cheers brother
man that was nice of him man that was
nice that's cool
you know because now in my head i
picture maybe she gets a little money
she does something kind of fun
something extra just some little thing
maybe she wasn't thinking
maybe she's gonna get a little breakfast
you know my mom used to like uh
she would do something like a nice
pancake breakfast but
she we had this gas powered skillet this
thing was
limited time they sold it and
uh and it burned a hole in the um
in the table one year but uh what else
do we have man
um hmm
[Music]
let me see what this call hi theo
this is susie again um i called you
earlier left a message
um i'm a single mom
i have been looking for this ps5
everywhere i'm from michigan and i'm
trying to get it for my daughter for
christmas
she's been doing really good in school
she's remotely completing high school
online right now and it's been
challenging but i'm very proud of her
she's been doing great
here in michigan we've been shut down
because of the rona
i feel you baby that dirty rona bro
that's that long aids baby let me call
you see what we can do
hello hey what's up who's this
hey it's susie
how are you what are you doing just
chilling i'm just what am i doing not
much
just drink some water just um making
some phone calls doing some podcasting
what are you up to
oh my gosh i'm actually cooking dinner
and cooking dinner from family
oh nice what are y'all having yeah mara
see how's on the phone uh we made some
we made raviolis green beans
and damn uh beans and
marinara sauce damn y'all must be rich
huh
no that sounds good are you a good cook
um pretty good i like to cook there we
go
um i want to thank you first of all just
first for thinking to somebody else and
just you know calling and leaving your
voicemail
um or not really thinking with somebody
else but of just thinking of you
of your daughter and uh
you know i thought it was really sweet
of you um the problem is we already gave
away the ps5 but i wanted to try and
think of something else that we could do
that you think would be nice
oh my god i don't even know what to say
when
um she's still upstairs by the way
um how about this i know it's kind of
impersonal but what if we just gave you
like a 500
gift card and you could do something
nice for you guys something that you
wanted to do
i know it's not a ps5 but um
no i appreciate it so much we've
we've been struggling i mean i try to
you know
you know my attitude is always positive
but
you know i'm i've been job searching
i mean it's tricky out there and look
i'll try to hear from you
just to hear from you is just
just wow
well that's sweet of you thanks you know
that makes me feel nice you know uh
but to hear from you was nice you know
you know and just to call and you know
um
i just i'm grateful to you guys that you
guys listen to to listen to the podcast
and just are a part of this group and
anyway yeah let me do that let me have
uh i'll have nick
or shawn follow up with you oh
thank you so much bill that the ps5 has
been just
crazy what i hear that's what i believe
it's like for christmas and i'm like oh
my god i can't believe anybody can even
afford those things those things are
like 900
bones man um i don't know
and yeah my family we were gonna you
know you know you know how
kids when they want something you gotta
pull through whatever they were gonna
give me a couple hundred on it or
whatever but you can't even get a hold
of it
yeah that's the thing because we thought
well maybe we'll buy someone try to
so um yeah so yeah we'd be happy to help
out in that sense and uh
yeah just thank you just thank you for
making my day and thanks for the nice
words
theo thank you thank you so much merry
christmas to you your family
like i love your podcast i can't wait to
hear the next one oh my god i don't even
know
wow thank you for the phone call yeah
y'all enjoy the raviolis and uh
you're welcome sushi for sure
for sure thank you you bet we love you
bye-bye
that's cool man making a little dinner
you know that's always nice
you know when i was a kid we always made
dinner my mom was always working so
you know we would always take turns
making dinner man and we would always
act like it was something different but
it was always macaroni
i mean i think it was macaroni for like
sixteen hundred nights in a row like it
was
always macaroni sometimes we get a can
and maybe some sliced pears or something
like that in their natural juice
all right let's take one more call right
here um thank you so much
hey pio um my name's caroline i'm from
gastonia north carolina right outside of
charlotte
um i'm a huge fan
of this past weekend and also king and
the scene
thank you so much thank you so much for
those nice words
my nephew was diagnosed with cancer
like a year and a half ago and it was
more this year like quarantined and
stuff when i started getting into
your podcast and um king and the sting
but i would like look forward to new
episodes
all the time like i was just so sad
and it really gave me something to look
forward to
oh thank you you know it's funny how uh
we all find kind of soulless and
different things you know some people
they want to listen to something
some people you know like a song we were
saying earlier it does something to you
some people they
you know you want to put your hands in a
mitten or something i used to have when
i was young this
i got a door mat from somewhere and i
put it in my room
so it was near the floor in my room by
the door
when you were leaving my room had a
doormat and sometime when i was sad i'd
go put my hands under it
for some reason and just sit there with
my hands under that doormat
and just i felt okay let's hear more um
but i was just listening to
your podcast and i heard about the um
the guy that has the playstation he was
wanted to donate
and um i my sister
um so my sister is 10 years older than
me
but um she has two kids and her oldest
son
adam he just passed away in october from
cancer um he was 16 and then she has
a younger son andrew and um
he will be 15 uh in the summer so
um he just lost his brother and i know
she was trying to find like
something like that like the new xbox or
the new playstation to give to him for
christmas that would kind of be special
but
well thank you so much for this uh
let's um let me see if i can get a hold
of you hey caroline
hello hey what's up this is theo i'll
call you called uh into the podcast the
other day from the podcast
oh my god
[Music]
oh damn well look just you know what i'm
saying keep your clothes on sorry i want
to get accused of nothing you know
oh my god i was literally just talking
about you
to my friend i was i'm like speechless
right now i was literally just talking
about you i was like i don't even listen
to music anymore
i just listened to leo vaughn in my car
and smile and just drive around
damn like 20 minutes ago and now listen
to your voicemail and now i can
my face is like pulsating
you might be on drugs i think damn i'm
not
i feel like i am but i'm not okay well
look it sounds like
if your damn faces pull satan you might
want to g up a little bit you might want
to
you know you might want to use a skin
softener or something
um no i just wanted to say your message
was so sweet i thought it was very nice
of you to call and uh
yeah we wanted to think of something
nice we could do because we already gave
away the playstation so i'm just trying
to think of something else fun that we
could do so
we're committed i think playstations are
just all sold out so we're committed to
help find like a um
xbox do you think the kids would want
that or do you think we should just wait
and
whenever playstations come back he
would prefer an xbox over the
playstation
i just heard that i say playstation i
was like you know what i'm going to call
sitting in my driveway listening to this
i've never called in
a sentence video or anything well thank
you
thanks for calling yeah thank you but
no he would prefer he's like a big
gamer so he's like plays on his computer
but he's been wanting the xbox so bad
but then when i heard that i was like
oh my god like playstation whatever i
don't
i don't even know the difference between
totally but i just
that he um if he got an xbox he would
poop in his pants well damn y'all's
whole family need to tighten up it
sounds like but uh
we're going through stuff but that's
okay look loosen up or tighten up that's
what they say man i do both sometimes
oh my god this is so crazy but look
we want to uh yeah we'd love to so
whether it's you know i'll have one of
the producers circle up with you and
then we'll figure out if
you know what what you guys want to do
for him if it's a
console or if we you know he wants games
i don't know you know it's sweet of you
to think of your of your nephew and we
want to
be a part of just uh you know making
christmas a little bit you know just do
whatever we can to help out
so there you go
thank you theo holy [ __ ] well i love you
over there
i love you too all right y'all be good
all right stay off them percocets girl
you know it
okay i will okay deal deal deal and i
will too
okay okay good okay deal
bye oh man that's great
that's sweet all right i think we had uh
you know
just a fun enough episode um
i'm really excited to announce that on
this
of january
uh january
15th at
p.m at 6 00 p.m pacific time
8 p.m central uh
theo and tammy who is chelsea lynn she
came on the podcast a while back we're
going to be doing a
live event it's going to have sketches
it's going to have musical guests
i'm nervous about it i never done no
sketches like that
but i am excited about it at the same
time i'm just trying to be brave
so you know we'll see what it is and
what it ain't
but it's new times man things you can
you can watch things live you could be
you'll be able to buy a ticket to it i
think the tickets are 10
it's going to be really neat we're
putting a lot into the production as
much as we can
i mean it's going to be oh lord i mean
they are wild
and a little gem is there in these
beautiful little just just a dam just a
little thick little
sugar termite bruh and he's beautiful
just one of god's damn bunions this
little fella
this little crispy cracker and uh but
it's anyway it's gonna be a lot of fun
and so i hope you'll join us that night
and check it out if you have a talent
or don't have a talent um
keep tabs on the this past weekend on
instagram we're gonna be uh
accepting talent and talented and
untalented people
because the show that we're putting on
is a belated christmas
talent extravaganza that's what it's
going to be and that's going to be on
january 15th so
uh be there be there it's going to be
cool
um what else man that's really it
you know we're heading into the holidays
um
and it's a weird year to go into the
holidays it feels strange
you know there's not as many places you
can go where the decorations are up and
some cities and towns aren't doing you
know even putting out putting up any
decorations just a weird year
uh but we still got each other baby
you know and even on tough days man i
know that that's the right
thing is not to give up on the people
around us
because they want us to out there they
want us to fight they want us to hate
you know they don't want me to go to a
black doctor they don't want me to go to
a uh
to a um middle eastern uh
chiropractor you know
we just got to keep just
we got to just keep connecting man
that's all it is
that's all it is baby um
you know in here and there we find
comfort
and i want you guys to be good to
yourselves man you deserve it and thank
you guys so much for
loving me and being a part of my life
this year i'm gonna play this same song
on the way out that we came in baby
uh larry fleets where i find god
you guys be good to yourselves man
[Music]
but not a hit rock bottom
sitting on an old barstool
he paid my tab and put me in a cab
but he didn't have to as he could see
i was hurting
[Music]
oh i wish i'd got his name
cause i didn't feel worth saving
but he saved me just the same come on
[Music]
floating
love you
so you guys find peace like this
and a bottle or a pill
[Music]
from a monastery
down
whether i'm looking for him or not
that's where i find god
come on larry come on larry
[Music]
heart sometimes the song
the cricket's the same i don't know
what they're saying
[Music]
but it sounds like a hymn to me
now i ain't too good at praying
but thanks for everything come on larry
come on
[Music]
whether i'm looking for him or not
that's where i'm
[Music]
me and him just
is
[Music]
hey man baby yeah
we got this everything's gonna be okay
you guys be good to yourselves man okay